CHANCE TO GET INTO THIS GAME.INK
AND HERE'S ANOTHER PLAY WITH
DRAW, A YOU DON'T PLAY IN
THIS BUILDING A LOT BUTUT>> ChrY
KNOCKED DOWN AS SHATTENKIRKTHOUT
COULDN'T GET ITDER TRIED TO GET
IT THROUGH.
LITTLE CURL BACK ON THE TOP AS
MARNER SLIDING BACK TO HIS LEFTN
ONONLEAFS CONTROL THE
DRAW HERET AS
BACK-TO-BACK GAMESNYLANDER.
SWAT AT IT BY THE STICK OF SECO.
MORGAN RIELLY AHEAD.
GETZLAF,ION.
HE'S GOT NO ONE.
HE'S GOT NO SHOT ACROSS, NO
PASSING LANE THERE OF THAT.
45 SECONDS LEFT ON THE POWER
PLAY.
NYLANDER, BACK TO MAR AS MARNER.
TRAVIS DERMO
THERE ARE RUMBLINGS OF AN NHL
DEAL FOR HIM POTENTIALAL WINGS O
THE LEAFS SEE NEXT ON Craig: NOR
WITH TAVARES ANDND BAR BUT
TONIGHT.
>> Craig: ESPECIALLY EARLY
DON'T YOU THINK,
RASMUS SANDIN'S GOT
THAT PASS, M
GOING TO FLIP THAT INTO GIBSON'E
YOU'RE NOT QUITE GOING AND CAN'T
GET YOUR OFFENSIVEOMES,
TREVOR ZEGRAS, A BAG OF TRICKS
AND HAS HALF A
SECOND.
SORT OF MOVE TO MAKE THE
GOALTENDER LEFT PAD
WAS ABLE TO KICK UP AND MAKE THE
SAVE.